[Music]
is a former member of chicago's second
city and annoyance theater starting
tomorrow he can be seen in rock of ages
and next friday in seeking a friend for
the end of the world with steve carrell
please welcome the very funny tj miller
[Applause]
[Music]
what up then shy town three one two it's
good to be back
yeah
real good
sorry i just scratched my chin like this
looked like an insult
you got to be a pretty cold-hearted
empty individual not to tear up even
just a little bit at the end of a
romantic comedy you know when the guy
gets the girl
and i started to tear up and i turned to
my girlfriend who was with me at the
time
you know because i wanted to say thank
you
thank you for loving me and accepting me
and letting me believe that true love
can be real
but as i turned to her before i could
say anything she just held up a calzone
that she had bought early at sabaros
and she said doesn't this look like a
double vagina
are you crying
what were you about to say
and i just said nothing the top part
looks more like a butt
i like that guy's laugh
[Laughter]
like a jack in the box that comes out
and then immediately stabs you
i'm not making fun of your laugh by the
way i would never do that you know you
ever had somebody make fun of the way
that you laugh
a friend of yours make fun of the way
that you laugh do you know that's
basically them saying that's basically
your friend saying hey you know that
sound that you make when you're happy
and joyful
and the tragedy that permeates our
everyday life is momentarily abated for
an escapist oasis
yeah you sound stupid
you should feel insecure when you're
happy
you should be like hi everything's okay
for a second wait do i sound like a seal
[Music]
like to do a couple of characters for
you guys this first character this is a
guy who whenever he's surprised by
something instead of doing a double take
he does a triple take
but the third take comes just a little
too late
hold on you paid how much for that
cereal
[Applause]
yeah that's it
this next character this is a fraternity
brother
who's giving a eulogy for the first time
melissa was really cool
[Music]
melissa was super awesome and a ton of
fun
melissa always said the society tried to
put us in our respective boxes and
restrict us but the cool thing about
melissa was she always said that her box
was big enough for everybody that's what
she said that's what she said
i did come up in the chicago scene and
so to close my set i would like to eat
two italian beef sandwiches in exactly
one minute
so these are italian meat thank you so
much you handed them to me like i was a
sensei
um
so these are italian beef sandwiches
they are a delicacy here in chicago
these are from portillo's chicago
so uh i i'm gonna eat these uh
in exactly one minute
uh
can i have a clock whoa
tbs
okay
now when i say
go not yet but when i say that we're
going to start the clock
okay
ready
set
go
you know what
i did i ate indian food before i came i
don't know why i did that i'm such an
idiot i saw indian food i was like well
i'll just have an appetizer or two
and i'd go in there what are you gonna
do order apps and not get a main course
it was that none too have you had that
you guys had that non i mean it is
delicious
it's like bread but better how much time
do i have
oh shoot okay here we go
ah
[Applause]
incredible
incredible
teacher ladies and gentlemen
be back